and it's not just Europe since the
financial crash of 2008 much of the
developed world has been enduring the
pain of stunted Economic Development
and this being has been visited on
developed Nations by a variety of
factors
now not every economy has been affected
by all of these factors but collectively
they've held back growth across the west
and we've seen in different countries
the over financialization of their
economies we've seen a naive trust in
the ability of authoritarian regimes to
be reliable partners corporate
structures that are sometimes called
executive rewards ahead of capital
investment
and of course bureaucratic reporting
requirements that are sometimes elevated
abstract goals that please pressure
groups ahead of concrete gains that
deliver for the poorest
we've also seen Supply chains that lack
resilience and in some countries
education systems that later again
and linking all of these phenomena has
been a preference amongst some policy
makers for models that appeal to
theorists and think tanks rather than
action rooted in real people and real
places
popular resistance to this model to
these factors and happiness with the way
in which shifted influence to
well-connected and often unproductive
Elites and move resources and economic
power abroad lay behind big political
shifts in the last 10 years not these
British decisions to leave the European
Union
it was notable there was no surprise
that the strongest support for brexit
came from communities in this country
that had suffered most over the years as
a result of a failure to get real
the weaknesses in the model that those
voters rejected have been more cruelly
laid bare than ever in recent years the
covert pandemic underlined just how
exposed we've become to risk as a
consequence of our economic Reliance on
regimes such as China
for essential finished goods and the war
in Ukraine has reinforced a significant
additional risk to all of us of being
reliant on authoritarian regimes for
energy
Nations and political systems that Joy
admire such as German have found their
dependence on Russian energy to fuel
manufacturing and Chinese markets to
sell their goods have left them in
severe difficulties
but there's no room for schadenfoider
here quite the opposite because lying
behind the 2016 vote was an awareness
that our own economic model in the UK
lacked in every sense real resilience
we've seen manufacturing declining over
decades government corporate and
personal debts too high energy supplies
have been insecure and transport
networks have been deprived of
investment a Workforce with huge talents
and potential but without the right
skills and qualifications
these weaknesses have been across the UK
in the foolish sense supply side
problems
we've had a problem with human capital
because our labor market has been
constrained by a lack of supply of
secretly qualified workers trained in
the UK particularly those the scientific
mathematical and Technical sense
and the supply of Finance Capital direct
investment in productive Industries has
also been limited by the structure and
regulation of financial services
the supply value manufactured goods that
we produce domestically has been held
back by both something about factors and
that in turn has exacerbated our current
account deficit reduced the number of
high paying jobs for all communities and
unbalanced the economy
historically poor productivity both
physical transport links and digital
infrastructure have added to our shared
economic challenges and past decisions
on energy investment perhaps most
conspicuously with respect to nuclear
power have left us dependent on the
unreliable foreign Partners not just for
supplies but for engineering engineering
expertise
Finance
these problems have been long-lasting
and they're deep-rooted as has one of
the most profound weaknesses in the
United Kingdom's political economy
the north south devoid
the UK as the ippr reminds us today has
suffered more than any of our neighbors
friends and Rivals from an enduring and
entrenched geographical and social
imbalance wealth influence Innovation
High productivity first how you age jobs
and high quality schools have been
disproportionately concentrated in the
south east quarter of the country
now none of that it's intended to play
down the vital importance to our economy
of our capital city probably the world's
single most attractive destination for
investment quite yours London is a
Priceless asset for all of us and as I
should go on to argue it's been a mod in
certain very specific ways
but we all know that we cannot Prosper
fully as a state if we rely so much on
one region and within that region on one
city
the UK economy has been like a football
team with a Star Striker but a Midfield
that consistently struggles to get the
ball up field and a defense full of
holes and no forward not even a Lionel
Messi can do it on his own
success depends on strength and depth
and that's what the UK economy has
lacked for too long we'd be
insufficiently resilient inherently
constrained by supply side weaknesses
and unequal in access to power capital
and investment
but while these problems have been
holding bitten back for decades this
government is committed to tackling them
head on price was made clear that the
moral imperative of reducing inflation
is at the heart of everything we do
because inflation reduces investment and
he's also made clear that he's committed
to generating sustainable growth across
the country
through Innovation and Enterprise
the chancellor has outline performs to
financial services to better support
industry and Manufacturing and of course
we have tax cuts like the super
deduction which further in the
centralized investment in productive
capital
the foreign and trade secretaries are
working to secure investors from abroad
in those areas in the UK which have been
overlooked and undervalued in the past
the work and pension secretary is
addressing in an economic inactivity
focusing particularly on our most
disadvantaged regions and the
educational secretary is tackling a
deprivation of route shifting resource
to where it's needed but geographically
and in children's life songs to extend
opportunity the transport secretary is
investing in improved links between and
within communities that have been
neglected in the past and the business
secretary is directing record research
and development money to historically
underfunded regions to ensure the spark
of innovation is nurtured across the
whole country I'll say more about all of
these initiatives in just a moment but
two truths are important to underline
nav
growth relies on using all of these
tools not just the fiscal and Regulatory
weapons which were governments disposal
and all of these initiatives work best
most fruitfully and sustainably when
we're working in partnership with
empowered strengthened economically
ambitious local leaders who honor our
equal Partners in the shared National
endeavor
I'll definitely not quite paper
published last year outlined how this
government plans to bring all of these
factors and forces together
and in the launch of the events of the
last 12 months it is more important than
ever as a guide to government action
recent economic challenges only
underline how powerful is the analysis
of the white paper and how important are
all its actions
the white people live at the steps
necessary to improve our country's
economic performance durably resiliently
and equity
it complements deployments dismay's
lecture and underpins the priorities
that he set out in a speech on the
government's agenda earlier this month
race together and reviewed alongside the
policies that we're implementing and
delivering on leveling up they
constitute a plan of economic action
which is both radical and evidence-led
is the growth strategy rooted in real
people and real places
other jurisdictions are also grappling
with the challenge of years into Decades
of low growth the U.S government
sensation reduction Act and the eu's
evolving response have provoked
understandable curiosity and debate but
the leveling up Point paper preceded
both of them and in both diagnosis and
detail it is just as ambitious the white
paper outlines that sustainable economic
growth relies on multiple interventions
to create the environment in which
private Enterprise can flourish
Innovation can take flight and new jobs
can be created
unless there are good schools with high
standards furthering higher education
institutions providing students with the
qualifications that employers value
unless there are effective transport
links within and between towns and
cities unless as fast and cost effective
digital connectivity and better access
to finance capital for local firms in
every part of the UK then growth cannot
be maximized across all communities and
of course for those communities to be
genuinely resilient to attract and to
retain the talent necessary to flourish
and to maintain economic competitiveness
that need to be safe streets and ordered
public spaces an attractive natural
environment and a beautiful built
environment colorful richness and
respect for Heritage the Civic
infrastructure that reflects the pride
that people have in the place that they
call her
and the best way to ensure that all of
these public goods are aligned is to
have strong accountable local Civic
leadership incentivized to work with
every actor who can reinforce these
virtuous science
on white paper identifies the need for
these changes and it sets out 12
National missions to ensure that we take
the steps necessary to embed growth in
every community
and these missions include clear and
stretching goals to eliminate illiteracy
and the numeracy to improve skills
object reduce Health inequalities
upgrade transport networks connect
communities digitally allocate our r d
funding more strategically tackle poor
quality housing improve wages and
productivity enhance pricing place and
extend the program of devolution that we
have been delivering until times so
committed
these missions all complement each other
are you making the central domestic task
of government to shift power wealth and
opportunity more evenly more equitably
across the country and in so doing
providing the foundations for durable
economic growth
now some of our dude in response to the
white paper but it is not the role of
government to provoke growth by acting
in this way but by absenting themselves
well I'm certainly no supporter of this
thing it's undesirable and inevitable
and continuing expansion
but I am against ever lengthening
welfare rules lives spent Independence
children brought up without the exam
passes that translate into jobs health
inequalities that will place growing
future demands on the NHS family
breakdown Lawless public spaces slum
housing which makes its inhabitants ill
and Civic institutions in decay all of
these Place greater pressure sooner or
later on the public posts and they are
reference to the conscience that no
government can ignore which is why there
is both immoral and economic imperative
to leveling up
and the experienced successful economic
transformation demonstrates that growth
is not secured by absent government but
by active government
a government that plays a strategic role
irrigating the soul for growth as
mustaches
technically in the documents
when the factory government took office
in 1979 London's doctrines were a
derelict economic desert their economic
rationale of goals containerization are
taking shipping away from the historic
Wars of burmansy and Poplar to new
purposeful thoughts jobs have
disappeared housing was slum level
schools were places of narrow Horizons
thinking hoops the original vision for
regeneration of the area from the
treasury of the time was simple
and deregulate
because when flowers would bloom in the
dusty and contaminated soil of the
dolphins
but while lower taxes and smarter
regulation are certainly powerful
ingredients in any great package they
just weren't enough
Margaret Thatcher and her Industries
then industry secretary Keith Joseph
tasked the environment secretary Michael
hasseldine with bringing together a
wider range of interventions through the
London docklands Development Corporation
land was assembled and remediated
through government agencies new
transport links were built including the
DLR and what was got London city area
new housing was commission and the due
course sporting and educational
investment followed the area that's
irrigated became fertile grown for
massive commercial Investments
government created the environment the
private sector created the jobs
a lot of the doctors today is an
economic success story one of the most
signaled success stories we owe to Mrs
fetches
and it is that spirit that animates our
leveling our policies
and that spirit is there most vividly in
our plans for new Investments
this country has no shortage of growth
industries whether an advanced
manufacturing renewable Industries or
the life sciences and with no shortage
of world-class universities including
here in Manchester
but where we've underperformed is
leveraging the success of those
Industries and research to support
growth across the whole country
particularly in communities in need of
regeneration that is my guiding mission
for investing zones and we will shortly
begin the process to identify investment
zones in areas that need leveling up
our approach will be going to buy three
principles first.com create clusters but
it can and has created the conditions
for them to succeed second success
requires fiscal support but also that
wide range of interventions that we saw
in Dockers whether that's land assembly
housing investor transport
infrastructure or skills invested in
order to ensure that we tackle the
specific barriers in each cluster that
hold that growth and of course third
investment zones can only happen in
partnership with strong local leadership
our new investment zones are intended to
deliver long-term change in the areas
where they're established and we
recognize that the scale of our leveling
up Ambitions means that we can't
accomplish all of the economic
strengthening and rebalancing of our
Nations overnight
and that's why our missions in the white
paper are deliberately designed to
extend beyond the lifetime of this
Parliament they are not exercises in
temporary amelioration or fiscal
elastoplasts this is a deliberately
long-term economic Flair and nowhere is
that more vividly demonstrated than the
scale of change and the level of
investment that we brought to devolution
we are reforming the shape and nature of
government in England itself
redistributing power and influence
within England just friends with cities
and communities outside London with the
north benefiting most of all
government itself of course has been
reshaped alongside this in the past just
proportionate number of the key
decision-making roles within the UK
government and the Civil Service were
located not just in the capital but in
one postcode that's changed the treasury
has now established a new campus in
Darlington staffed by senior officials
and recruiting locally the economic
factors of the nation now increasingly
have those in manufacture and the
renewable sector is their neighbors not
hedge funders and pressure groups we've
also established second headquarters for
my own Department in Wolverhampton for
the camera office in Glasgow and for the
NHS and leads alongside establishing a
home office Center of Excellence still
and the new Cyber defense establishment
in Salisbury near Preston
so far 20 000 senior posts have been
relocated out of London to the north in
the places for growth program with more
to follow
but while relocating sexual government
decision making is important even more
critical is empowering local decision
making through meaningful durable
devolution
now I hope I don't need to rehearse in
front of this audience the benefits the
strong mayoral leadership has brought
most notably in Greater Manchester the
West visions and the teas Valley
before 2010 the only significant
evolution in England had been to London
now strong Mayors in all our major
cities are acting as agents of economic
growth
the impact of bad function of leadership
in teas Valley for example has been
transformational an airport revived in
our Abyss Freight and passenger Talent a
new Freeport regenerating thousands of
acres and bringing tens of thousands of
new jobs
further education college is working
more closely than ever with employers a
world-leading destination for investment
and offshore wind and home to a new
freeze backed by the leading
educationists in the country see someone
just proof that putting economic
development in the hands of an empowered
and energized local leader works and
that's why today I'm delighted to back
then with new powers for the
establishment of two new mayoral
development corporations in teas Valley
to drive regeneration in the town
centers upon the pool and middle school
they will make a major contribution to
leveling up and they will attract
businesses and people back to these
centers
Ben's success deserves to be reinforced
as does that the Mayors in Greater
Manchester and the West Midlands now
while I would always agree with Andy
Burnham indeed it would be fatal for his
political career if I did
I must acknowledge that both Andy
Burnham and Andy Street have used the
mayoral model powerfully and effectively
for their communities both recognized
that the mayor's Central role is
economic development driving growth and
the Regeneration projects that they're
delivering are turning Daryl brownfields
into nurseries of investment the greater
Manchester housing investment fund for
example has seen 420 million pounds
worth of spending unlock an additional
5150 homes across 40 sites in the city
region and it's because of the success
of Andy Burnham and Andy Sweet that were
currently in talks with both greater
Manchester and the West Midlands to
strengthen the hands of both mirrors we
want to devolve even more housing fund
including exploring more control of the
affordable homes program in West
Midlands and greater Manchester at the
moment London is the only Memorial
Authority controlling the affordable
homes program budget and if we want more
of the homes we need in the places where
they're needed and we want to regenerate
Brownfield science and drive growth I
believe Devolution of this budget is
vital and necessary
and as well as working with combined
authorities to improve Supply to
increase the quantity of new homes I
also want to collaborate on improving
the quality of existing events one of
our key leveling up missions is driving
up the standard of housing across the
country
and making sure that all homes are warm
safe and decent
because we know that poor housing kills
the tragic death of ishak in Rochdale
Wright really enforce the need for
action and improving the quality of
homes in which every citizen lives is
not in the leveling up Mission but a
personal mission for me I've been
inspired by the work of people like Dan
Hewitt and quite above who've campaigned
for tenances and has been blight by
terrible housing conditions today we're
going fur in our drive to make every
home a decent home we'll be allocating
30 million pounds for greater Manchester
and the West Midlands to start making
improvements in the quality of social
housing funding divorce directs the
Mayors to make a difference to real
people in real places
but while improving your housing quality
is a passion it is of course one of
multiple missions the missions in the
white paper extend across government and
so do the powers that we also plan to
devolve which extend far beyond those
like housing directly within the control
of my department
that's why we're also looking to devote
more control over further and Technical
education transport trade culture and
employment support
and because accountability is key to
effective delivery of these new powers
will also improve the knowledge that all
voters have about the performance of all
local leaders our new office for local
government are flawed will produce
detailed and precise comparison of
delivery across local authorities and
may all combined authorities value for
money and effective list of service will
be measured uh more effectively than
ever before it will be monitored
analyzed so we can learn from the best
and support others to improve and I'd
love to join us today that any ismos
Lord Wars the former head of the
National Audit office has agreed to
chair this new body and my department
will launched a competition to find a
chief executive to lead the organization
in the days ahead
I'm confident that this will be another
step in enhancing the role that local
leaders play in our political lives and
in delivering economic growth because I
believe this greater scrutiny will not
only further sharpen efficiency and
spread learning it will I know show how
successful Devolution is can and will be
in the future
we've already made huge progress in
extended Evolution across the north with
a new MCA bringing emerging North
Yorkshire for the first time and an
extended deal coming this month for the
Northeast with 1.4 billion pounds I'd be
clear that my ambition is to finish the
job and to give all parts of England the
work one a Devolution deal by 2030. soon
75 of the north will have a deal with
positive discussions in the remaining
areas which I look forward to developing
later this year in the white paper we
made clear will return to the
conversational Devolution in cumber once
we're through the important process of
local government reform I might also
want to see Evolution not only in
Cumbria but in Lancashire in Cheshire
and Warrington and in Hull and East
Yorkshire and I look forward to picking
up those conversations later those years
working hand in hand with a fantastic
leveling up Minister Diego Davidson
who's been so intimately involved in
getting these deals over the life Dana
apologizes for not being able to join
you today sadly business in Westminster
has kept her in London I know that uh
for Deanna as for me being kept in
London is punishment not Liberation so
Deanna sends her apologies and I uh send
my best wishes to her now I'm very
conscious of course that the mayor role
model has its critics and Skeptics I'm
particularly conscious that communities
on the periphery of mayoral geographies
sometimes whether their needs can be
overlooked but I don't think there's a
tension between Manchester success or
sunderland's growth in Spain Wars or
indeed newcastle's prosperity and Belize
regeneration attracting investment to
magnet cities is a necessary part of
Reviving The Economic fortunes of
satellite towns and indeed if we unlock
a potential of all our major cities and
the way that Manchester is doing then
the whole country bears improving the
productivity of the nine UK second
citizens uh will add buildings to the UK
economy
but of course if every Community within
MCAS is to Bear to the full that means
even more effective transport links
within those communities and that's why
mayoral deals including our deal in the
Northeast now involve specific funding
for City Regional sustainable transport
improvements and we're back in all ncas
in their bids to improve bus services
and of course white paper commits to
helping other cities emulate Andy
Burnham and greater Manchester's B
Network to establish london-style
integrated Transport Systems across
their geographies
but there are communities that are
geographically beyond the boundaries of
the old combined authorities and
relatively distant from the uh faster
great cities which also require specific
bespoke attention from government
colorful communities in particular where
economic changes meant the employment
opportunities of the past have faded and
that's why in dealer we've developed
particular Partnerships with communities
such as Blackpool and Gracie to
determine what direct faction is
required to drive growth in those
communities the quality of housing the
attractiveness of the Town Center poor
educational standards and expectations
and the feeling of local disempowered
have held back Economic Development and
that's why we're investing directly in
improving housing quality in those areas
regenerating the urban part of those
great times and blocking transport
bottlenecks and improving Technical and
further education as well as investing
directly in strengthening Civil Society
we recently invested 30 million pounds
to help the Council of fire public land
necessary for the effective remodeling
of the town center and just last week 40
million pounds from the leveling up fund
was deployed to help to create a new
higher education center the multiversity
which will promote more high quality
courses which are designed in
collaboration with local employers
now I know that the allocation of
leveling up fund investment last week
attracted Lively comment across the
country
the more people discussing leveling up
the happier I am
but it is important to bear in mind that
the 2.1 billion pounds allocated last
because it's a small fraction of our
overall standard leveling up and the
fund is specifically designed to
complement the many other policies and
significant additional spending outlined
in the white paper I didn't apologize
for a moment for using Vehicles like the
leveling up fund to invest additional
government money in communities outside
current ncas such as Blackpool acting
and working between clear force and at
fields we are active engaged and
committed across the country
the leveling up phone of course adds to
the significant increase in local
government standing and acts in the
standing review and of course
um uh it adds to the 2.6 billion pounds
of the UK shared Prosperity fund over
625 million pounds of which is going
directly to local authorities in the
north and that's spending further
compliments the further additional
funding that may oral combine
authorities have rightly skewered
through their default investment funds
Evolution deals concluded last year and
that's on top of the billions already
allocated through the towns and High
Street funds and indeed the very first
line of leveling upon spending last year
and I can confirm there'll be a further
round of investment from the leveling up
funnel after the March budget alongside
more Capital funding for MCAS and
further support for local government
now I'm always able to discussion about
how we can further refine how we deliver
the funding for everything how we can
give local communities more control
I do believe that a competitive process
is allocating funding can it help to
drive Innovation and ensure rigorian
delivery but I do recognize that there
is a need to reduce the bureaucracy
involved in the main repetitive bidding
processes which have grown up over time
and that's why I'm working with the
chancellor to simplify funding and
allocations and extend local government
autonomy again more details after the
March budget
as they said
it's not just D lock that is he leveling
up the pond every government bot is
committed to our mission we're committed
to using every tool at our disposal to
drive Economic Development so that's why
we're increasing public investment in
research and development to 20 billion
pounds a year with Grant shafts ensuring
more of this funding is spent outside
the southeast and this includes
significant investment in the north
already
222 million pounds for approach type
fusion power plant in Nottinghamshire 22
million for Fusion technology in
Rotherham helping both become a growing
hubspan at zero and 15 million pounds
for Innovation pilots in the teas Valley
and Liverpool
our future depends on catalyzing
Industrial investment whether it's
Battery Technology improved power
transmission networks more efficient
Renewables infrastructure carbon
capturing storage hydrogen Ai and
Robotics the synthetics Revolution Gene
editing modern methods of construction
metallurgical materials technology zero
carbon Aviation and Quantum Computing
drone development or a plethora of other
new and evolving Technologies the future
will be shaped by high value
manufacturing and of course the north is
at The Crucible of the growth of high
value Manufacturing all national
resilience instruments depends on our
Embrace for these opportunities and as
Governor rights to the Center for social
Justice's reminders high value
manufacturing is the route to higher
employment everywhere higher wages and
higher National productivity
but one factor which
I'd like to accelerate to the the end I
certainly will yeah no no no no no
but one factor which has held back to
the investment we all want to see has
been sclerosis in the planning system
for the major projects which Drive
significant growth and that's why you
will shortly deliver the next stage of
our drive to accelerate the process of
securing Financial consent by making
sure that we publish an action plan
which will set our reforms to the
nationally significant infrastructure
projects regime this will streamline and
speed up the consenting process it will
boost investor confidence major
infrastructure and it will help the
government to improve energy security
achieved at zero and deliver better
transport connectivity
this reforms the planning process stands
alongside the reforms to financial
services outlined by the chancellor in
Edinburgh last year which will make
Finance work better for industry and
bring growth back home and to make the
most of these opportunities we also need
a Workforce equipped with technical
schools that the new Industries require
one of the unheralded successes of the
last 12 years has been the growth of a
number of students leaving schools with
exactly the skills required especially
high quality science and maths
qualifications but I'm very aware that
the benefits of educational reform have
so far accrued disproportionately to
students in the South and especially in
London and that's why we're supporting
the best multi-academy trusts to grow
and to extend their opportunities across
the North Star Academy Sports for
example have already shown the way with
new academically ambitious free schools
being established in Preston Blackburn
and Bradford
now good tools indeed Great Schools act
not just the springboards for existing
students they also contribute to
improving the attraction of communities
for inward investment and incoming
talent and that's because the quality of
life within communities is as important
as any other factor in the Alchemy of
success
and that's why we're increasing funding
through the Arts Council in culture
outside London and it's also why we are
strengthening our new community
ownership fund which enables local
people to take back control of assets
that have been degraded by others uh in
a way which that Community has been left
Feeling disempowered by and our
community ownership fund working with
Andy was able to give supporters of
Barry the chance to take back control of
gig length and there are other
initiatives the community ownership fund
will be supporting in the future
but as well as reinforcing these
successes we also need to be even more
energetically tackling those factors
which Mar the quality of life for too
many communities
that means focused action on High Street
dereliction and in particular greater
zero encountering anti-social Behavior
that has been graffiti drug taking and
drug dealing vehicle crime and the
intimidation of women girls all are more
likely to flourish in the holiday parts
of communities where neglect is slowly
taken hold the broken windows phenomenon
is a cliche in the discussion of crime
and social behavior because it's true
the unoccupied and unloved become the
disused and derelict and queer care is
in every sense absence chaos finds an
opportunity and that is why we will
shortly publish an action plan on
anti-social Behavior uh our
determination ambition is high we'll
have stronger and tougher enforcement of
existing Powers specific delivery of
immediate Justice with those damaged
local assets deployed to repair them and
will be investing more in young people
and the activities available to them and
alongside these tools we will tackle
Public Drug taking including the use of
nitrous oxide and Ford enhanced
Community Police with the better use of
data and faster responses to complaints
driving faster and fairer economic
growth go together right finished
another minute yeah go and nationally
succeeds but it mobilizes every
Citizen's talent and potential but that
can only happen through local and
central government civil society and the
private sector all playing their part
and it will always and everywhere be the
private sector that creates the new jobs
and which economic growth and individual
fulfillment depend but for the private
sector to grow for the Promethean Spirit
of entrepreneurs to take away we do need
to ensure that our society is
institutions and all our communities are
included in a common National Enterprise
that's what our leveling up the fact she
does it places the innate value of every
single citizen at the heart of economic
decision it refuses to accept that any
life Community or region cannot be made
to flourish and to contribute to a
greater National renewal it places
greater National resilience and economic
economy within a framework of strengths
and Civic institutions and stronger
local Pride its season rigorous
education The Roots leading in the high
value manufacturing industries of the
future
tax economic inactivity and it holds
local loyalties it cherishes earning and
Below nationally local individly
economically ambitious socially just
politically Central and morally urgent
that is what our leveling up strategy
means for this stuff
that was a very substantial speech a
long a long and very substantial speech
and I hope I didn't curtail and no force
you to cut out cut out very important
right like like a co-driver
you know star in a reasonably priced car
you made sure that I accelerated
there were some of the small
announcements uh
30 million for social housing around
here there was a critique of the